hello everybody my name is dr jennifer
stone i'm a senior manager of product
marketing and the oncology business unit
at illumina
and today it's my great pleasure to
share with you
some information regarding
the development of technologies to
really transform oncology with genomics
so to start us off uh just a little bit
of review information for those of you
familiar with this space
the war on cancer was declared almost 40
years ago now over 40 years ago now and
as you can see from this chart here
despite billions of dollars and and tons
of research into this
disease
the needle really hasn't moved too much
in terms of overall mortality from
cancer you can see in the red line
across the years here it stayed pretty
consistent while there's been great
strides in for example diseases of the
heart
decreases there and
with more scientific discovery and so it
really begs the question what what does
the world what does the community need
to do to really
understand cancer and be able to fight
cancer more intelligently
it's a huge world health problem it
doesn't uh just affect the rich or the
poor it's something that we all have to
deal with uh around the world uh with um
high incidence rates in western europe
and north america australia but
certainly a situation that all of global
health organizations need to deal with
on a daily basis with lung cancer being
the highest most prevalent cancer and
breast cancer a close second after that
but incidence is only one aspect of this
equation here
many people get sick it's really a
question of can you effectively treat
the disease and can you control the
disease such that people can live
longer healthier lives
and so
on some level perhaps the most important
statistic here is going back to
mortality figures if we look at breasts
prostate cancer there's high
incidence
but actual mortality from those cancers
is on the low side compare that to
something like lung where the incidence
is extremely high and
mortality from lung cancer is also
extremely high and so it begs the
question
what can we do better to really move the
needle on this disease
i put up on the slide a couple of recent
figures one from the u.s one from the uk
about 10 of cancer in the us is
diagnosed at stage 4 and about 50
percent in a recent report from cruk
show that cancer is being diagnosed at
later stages and this is an important
consideration when we think about the
options available for patients as well
as what we can do again to really change
the paradigm and influence that
mortality statistic that we looked at on
the first slide
so the reality of cancer treatment and
this is an oversimplification
so i apologize to those of you who know
this in intimate detail but the reality
is surgery is the only
proven and established cure for cancer
at the end of the day if you can
surgically remove the cancer in its
entirety
the patient is free and clear and can go
on to live a healthy life
for those patients that are not detected
until later stage or have unresectable
tumors really chemotherapy some sort of
systematic systemic therapy or
personalized medicine are two of the the
only available options to those patients
and this is an important
aspect because a lot of the conversation
that we talk about when we think about
genomics and oncology is really focused
at the use of genomic information in
either diagnostic companion diagnostic
or prognostic situation so the patient
is already diagnosed
what i'd like to share with you today is
actually a vision that's much greater
than that for oncol for genomics and
oncology a vision that includes
understanding the role of germline
variation in oncology using our
technologies to to potentially crack
open healthy screening and push back the
timeline and the age and the stage at
which cancers can be detected thereby
providing patients with a broader array
of treatment options
to use our technology to monitor
treatment progress and treatment
effectiveness in real time
and to use our technology uh for for
more of a recurrence monitoring
recurrence um
screening type paradigm very similar to
the healthy screening type concept
to this end illumina is working on three
strategic pillars in the oncologist
space the first one is focused on
germline variation which has a critical
role certainly in germline risk
estimates but is also increasingly
important in diagnostic and companion
diagnostic type scenarios
we're also looking at molecular
monitoring it's a critical area of
product development and as you can see
here molecular monitoring can
potentially bring benefit down the road
across
at least four of these five um
stages on sort of a a clinical care
cycle for oncology everything from
companion diagnostics liquid biopsies
for example monitoring treatment
progress again recurrence monitoring and
then eventually someday perhaps in the
use of healthy screening
and underlying it all is the fundamental
understanding of tumor biology
not only understanding uh specific
mutations in the dna but how does
translate into uh expression signatures
how how the methylome looks there's a
huge complexity of cancer biology that
is still being unraveled and we'll talk
through some of those in the coming
slides
so starting first with germline variance
in cancer
it's pretty well established an estimate
at least that about five to ten percent
of cancers have a hereditary component
it's also uh recently been established
that knowing one's germline status for
example their brachial one and two
status or their p10 status can be an
important biomarker for various
pharmaceutical interventions for example
parp inhibitors
to that end illumina has developed over
the past couple years a targeted panel
called the true site cancer panel this
has been designed in collaboration with
professor nazni rahman
at the institute of cancer research in
london and the whole goal here is to
design a reagent that allows for
large-scale testing large-scale
sequencing of huge numbers of people so
that we can really establish the
statistical power to understand the role
that variants and germline dna are are
playing
in in the individuals cancers
there's still a huge amount of research
to be done here
but some of the critical sort of usual
suspect genes are of course included in
this
in this panel so whether we're looking
for colon cancer breast cancer
kidney cancer etc etc melanoma
retinoblastoma the usual suspects are
all included here and they're being used
today in the research laboratory of dr
nazney and ramen among other
leaders in this field to really tease
apart what's the role of gene sorry
germline variation in cancer
as i mentioned also the role of germline
variation is very is
emerging as an important biomarker in
the pharmacology space as well and right
here i just have a few screenshots from
recent papers have been published that
are exploring that fact and really uh
building the body of evidence to support
the testing of germline variation as a
routine
component of any cancer patient's workup
so moving on to tumor biology and tumor
profiling
here i have a figure that
is referring to the great work that's
been done by numerous organizations
around the world
the cancer genome atlas afterward or the
tcga program as well as that
international cancer genomics consortium
the icgc
both of these efforts are huge
international
working groups that are looking to
explore and really map out in detail
the biology of what it means to be a
tumor what it means to be a cancer cell
and while there's
many many people involved here and you
can see i think that's indicative of the
geographic spread represented in the
figure here
it's too much to go through at this
point in time but suffice it to say some
of the important findings that come out
of this work really highlight not only
the differences between cancer and the
differences between cancers of different
tissue types but the similarities as
well and so we're moving to an era where
instead of being solely defined on
tissue of origin
cancers are certainly defined on that
category as well but also defined on
their molecular makeup both dna
variation expression patterns epigenetic
patterns etc and all of this information
allows researchers to really understand
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
a cancer cell or a tumor mass and how
can they be exploited to treat patients
better
this particular analysis i'm
highlighting here was published last
year this is a paper that came out of
the tcga pan cancer analysis effort it's
really a tour de force and the first
time that so many different tumor
samples were looked at in mass across so
many different tumor types historically
these sorts of analyses were done as a
single tumor type in sort of an isolated
and relatively small scale type of
experimental setting
in this particular example they looked
at 12 different pan cans sorry 12
different tumor types from the tcga
project and you can see them listed
there along the top and looked at the
they performed an analysis on whole
exome sequencing from these cancer
samples and looked at number
numerous different factors about those
those samples looking at differences in
mutation rates looking at the mutational
spectrum and the mutational signatures
of those cancers how are they similar
how are they different and as we add
this additional layer of molecular
complexity to our understanding of tumor
biology we can then again use this in
more intelligent drug design more
intelligent therapeutic regimen design
as well
now the tcga project has delivered a
huge wealth of information that's being
used by researchers around the world
both within the tcga and icgc projects
as well as uh
numerous other people around the world
that are mining that information
but it begs the question how much is
enough and and have we really discovered
all that there is to know about cancer
cells and can we just move forward into
other lines of inquiry and i put this
slide in here to highlight the fact that
there's still a huge amount to discover
this is a paper that was published
earlier this year
lawrence at all in nature and they asked
the question of those
uh of those data sets that are available
for thousands of different cancers
across dozens of different tumor types
currently available out of tcga
data
what additional information is being
identified with each incremental sample
that's analyzed
and so as we look at the graph here
going along the x-axis
starting at zero and going up to close
to five thousand different tumors
we see that the number of new variants
new genes being identified at a mutation
frequency for example at twenty percent
the red line it's kind of leveling out
and so that's indicative of the fact
that we've really found as a community
the genes that are mutated most often in
cancers
20 and above we've identified those
genes
if we change and look at genes that are
mutated less frequently so let's say
three to five percent looking at the
light blue line you'll see that that's
increasing and no sign of leveling off
and this is suggestive of a huge amount
of additional discoveries that need to
be made that are in the lower frequency
range meaning those genes are not not
mutated in a high fraction of patients
or a high fraction of tumors but they
are significant
in a non-trivial fraction of the overall
cancer population
and so the conclusions of this paper
were while
highly mutated genes
genes are mutated at high frequency have
for the most part been found uh based on
this analysis intermediate frequency
down to about two percent for example
will require huge numbers of samples to
complete this catalog to really
understand what the full spectrum of
mutation of mutations are within what we
call quote unquote cancer which is as we
all know an amalgamation of many many
diverse different diseases
their estimation would be that you need
about 2 000
tumors from each of about 50 different
tumor types to
really map this out down to about two
percent frequency and this corresponds
to about an
a total of a hundred thousand different
tumors so as these projects continue on
they'll clearly be making more and more
discoveries um and adding to this body
of work now i should point out that this
is just looking at dna variation it's
not even touching the role of rna or
epigenetics and those are additional
very important lines of inquiry that are
going on by tcga icgc as well as many
other groups around the world
i do want to highlight though that you
know one of the
one of the comments that i often get and
that many of us often get is well you
know what's the importance of a two
percent a gene that's mutated in two
percent of patients what what role is
that really going to do for anybody but
i do want to highlight that crisotinib
which is a really successful
personalized therapy
is targeting out translocations which
are only present in about three to seven
percent of lung cancer patients
so you know not high on the mutation
scale those those alk translocations but
a clear success story for um the
development of personalized therapies
and and exemplified by the story that
we've seen with chronzotinib so i would
argue that going down to two percent um
and understanding the genes that are
mutated at these intermediate
frequencies is an important endeavor for
the the world community to continue
so in summary for the discovery work on
tumor biology there's been over 120
significant mutated genes have been
discovered by the tcga group
and there's been over 550 genes and 120
different fusion genes identified in the
cosmic database so
while we've been able to take the full
catalog of the human exome down to a on
the order of hundreds of genes that
we're interested in that's still a
significant number of genes that need to
be followed up and investigated
for
in more of a clinical research context
so how do we take what's emerging in
terms of the complexity of cancer
biology and try to push that along the
product development cycle to really
develop next generation clinical
products that bring these discoveries to
bear and personalized medicine this is a
process that's going to be ongoing for
many years
and something we are trying to support
and i have tried to coin the term or use
the term that's been coined by other
people of theranostics to describe the
work that we're doing here
and it really starts with one of the
challenges that um
pathologists and oncologists are facing
today and
today they're facing a challenge just a
workflow challenge really
in getting patients access to
personalized therapeutics for example in
this in this slide we've got a
hypothetical lung cancer biopsy let's
say it gets tested for egfr it's either
wild type or it's not um if it's wild
type we then maybe test it for for alk
translocations it's either wild type or
it's not and so you can see there's this
sequential testing
that happens to to a potential patient
sample
and this iterative testing increases
demands for tissue that's always in
scarce supply certainly increases the
time to action and time is precious for
these patients and costs overhead labor
to support all this sequential testing
the reason for this paradigm is that the
majority of these companion diagnostic
tests affect all of these companion
diagnostic tests today have been
developed starting with the drug first
so there's a drug that looks promising
uh the the pharmaceutical companies and
clinical researchers that are supporting
bringing this through clinical trials
look for a biomarker that's suggestive
of action in a subset of patients and
then that biomarker becomes the
companion diagnostic that's the paradigm
for how it works today
the challenge is um that thus far in the
united states has only been 12 companion
diagnostic tests approved for
personalized therapies in cancer
but the pipeline is huge and so we're
looking at somewhere over 500 depending
on who you ask personalized therapeutics
and development today and so if we take
the complexity of the pharmacopoeia
that's coming down the pipe in addition
to the complexity of cancer that's
emerged from the recent studies that we
just walked through you can see sort of
the factorial combination of all those
different variants plus drug
combinations etc becomes an intractable
problem again when you're dealing with
limited time money and available tissue
uh certainly not extensible in not not
um
uh not
not achievable not explorable given the
current paradigm of testing
so one of the things that illumina is
working to try to support is changing
that paradigm to start with the patient
patient-centered oncology therapeutics
where the patient starts at the center
the next step is then understand the
biology of that patient's tumor really
understand the mutations that that tumor
is carrying and then use that
information for for informed drug
selection um either
and and use that um to really pair the
patient to the right drug at the right
time saving valuable time money um and
labor for
the patient and the doctor
so changing the paradigm instead of
having this sequential one-off testing
the future the future that we're trying
to develop tools for looks something
similar to this where there's a cancer
biopsy the this universal oncology test
is then applied to that cancer biopsy
and there's either an actual variant uh
with an approved informed therapy
available or if there's no actionable
variant detected potentially
looking at additional variants and then
enrolling that patient into a clinical
trial if available and so it really cuts
down on the the waste right now quite
frankly of tissue time and and money to
support patient testing
now illumina is certainly not the
experts in uh cancer biology we're we're
our technology company for um
historically and so we've engaged uh the
the in the expertise of a number of
different cancer centers um
around the united states we formed the
actual genome consortium which was
announced a few a few weeks ago
including dana farber fred hutch md
anderson and sloan kettering
all four of these institutions are
providing insight into us into what is
truly actionable and how do we how do we
define um a set of genes and a set of
criteria
that can be standardized and and shared
with the broader oncology and pathology
communities
but certainly the pharma the
pharmacopoeia is the other side of this
equation
and essential to making this entire
strategy work is to pair uh both sides
of this equation together and so on the
pharma side we've announced three
partnerships um with one with
astrazeneca one with jansen and one with
sanofi
to really work to develop a universal
test that can be used in clinical trials
and put on proper paths towards
regulatory approval
the goal here is to develop an ecosystem
where the universal test and the patient
are at the center and important players
in this entire
exercise clearly are the farmers as
we've already discussed in the cancer
centers but engaging with the fda early
and often as well as members of the
extended
cancer center network and clinical trial
network across the united states
bringing in biotechs as well as the cros
that perform much of this clinical trial
work with the goal of
standardizing something that's lacking
in the clinical
development of ngs today
streamlining such that this massive
pipeline of new uh potential
therapeutics has a very clear path to um
companion diagnostics and the
introduction of new biomarkers can be
done in a much more streamlined and
efficient way
decentralization to allow genomic
testing uh via standardization and the
streamlined aspects of this program
decentralizing it closer to where
patients are actually treated
it also allows for a mechanism for
investigation and collaboration amongst
pharma cancer centers ourselves as
technology developers and the other
members of this ecosystem so that these
discoveries can move very very quickly
from
just a finding through to something that
can be brought to bear on many patients
across the world
and now switching to our third topic
this is molecular monitoring and this is
basically using deep sequencing to
detect and monitor cancer
what we're going to talk about today is
the deep sequencing of cell free dna
many of you may be familiar with the
huge change in trisomy testing bringing
nipt on board looking for
fetal dna within the maternal dna
bloodstream
very similar concept what we can do in
cancer as well sequencing the fragments
of dna that are floating around in a
patient's
bloodstream and being able to use that
information to detect indicative somatic
variation
pardon me
so one of the quick one of the important
questions is can we detect cancer
earlier
and so we hinted that at the beginning
of this program that despite population
level screening programs we're still as
a community detecting many many cancers
at late stage which limits the treatment
options available for those those
particular individuals and this is a
statistic from a recent report from the
cdc that almost half of the colorectal
cancer
and cervical cancers and a third of the
breast cancer cases in the united states
are diagnosed at late stages late stages
meaning that cancer has metastasized and
spread to other parts of the body
and why well there's a number of reasons
for this
one is lack of compliance for example
or lack of access based on where
patients live or the the healthcare they
have available
lack of a screening test many many
cancers don't have a screening test or
certainly not a
population population level screening
program in place and then poor
sensitivity of some of these tests as
well
so what we're proposing here and what
others are proposing is is can we use
the power of deep sequencing to develop
a screening test
that was non-invasive for example didn't
involve a colonoscopy was low cost
easily performed and available for a
broader range of different cancer types
the idea here would be to use blood
which is a readily available tissue and
highly informative as a source for
biomarkers that may be a solution to
this problem
so there's a number of different groups
that are really blazing the trail
in this particular area of inquiry
and a couple i'll highlight a couple of
them in this talk one of them is a group
out of johns hopkins
and this is a paper by beta gauda
earlier this year that used whole genome
sequencing and whole exome sequencing to
identify driver mutations from tumor
samples in about 600 different patients
they then use this information
to inform the development of targeted
sequencing panels to identify those same
driver mutations identified from the
tumor samples in the plasma of those
individuals from the plasma dna of those
individuals
and they were able to show that the
presence of the tumor they dna using
this approach was it was the the they
were able to detect somatic mutations
from the tumor sample dna at an earlier
at early stage in the plasma and this is
a significant finding because there was
always the question of well perhaps you
can only detect
tumor dna in the plasma of patients at a
very late stage um how informative is
that if the patient's already very sick
so this this particular study you can
see in the figure on the left-hand side
shows that in localized disease which
were equating to earlier stage disease
here you can still detect the presence
of tumor somatic mutations
in the dna at a high frequency and so
this would suggest the extensibility of
these approaches to earlier stage
patients it's a it's a very important uh
proof of principles that you suggest um
the true promise of this approach going
forward and certainly this will be
followed on by larger uh studies that
that um look deeper and earlier into the
plasma of various patients
another study that also came out of the
johns hopkins group and this is an older
one from a few years ago but i think a
really nice one that that highlights uh
what what is possible and sort of the
types of signals that one can identify
from plasma dna
in this one lyria all used whole genome
sequencing of plasma samples to develop
a plasma aneuploidy score
and they then applied this uh to
uh to
a series of normal individuals as well
as a series series of late stage
metastatic breast and colorectal cancer
patients
interestingly the range of uh tumor
fraction within the blood across these
very late stage patients was highly
variable ranging from about 1.4 to about
50 percent of the the floating uh plasma
dna
excuse me dna in those samples
but i think the graphic from this paper
is is extremely informative and
highlights the power of this approach
you can see in the black
bars that are on the left-hand side of
the graph
those are the signals of this
quote-unquote aneuploidy score from the
normal samples included in the study and
you can see that they are
nearly flat across the board
this is in contrast to the metastatic
patients the colorectal cancer patients
and the breast cancer patients which
across the board
have signals off the charts if you will
here but a clear clear separation
between what is normal in terms of
aneuploidy in the bloodstream versus
what is
indicative of cancer in this particular
study
a limited proof of principle studies a
study only looking at 20 patients but i
think a really nice and clear signal of
the power and the potential of this
approach going forward
another aspect another another
application for deep sequencing of
plasma dna is monitoring cancer in real
time
so in this study researchers are
investigating the sequencing of cell
free dna from plasma for monitoring as
well this is newman at all published
earlier this year in nature medicine um
and they use targeted sequencing of
plasma samples to monitor tumor burden
during treatment what's really
interesting here is you can see um how
they they compare the signal of somatic
variation in the bloodstream
which is the red line in both of these
graphs here to
alternative methods for monitoring the
effectiveness of treatment in this case
the blue
triangles are are referring to
the volume as established by imaging
methods
and so in in the first panel in uh panel
a you can see that the molecular
signature from the plasma dna drops to
zero and is correlated
roughly with what they're seeing from
the tumor volume uh data as well
um
similarly in b so you can see very close
correlation between um the the amount of
circulating tumor dna in the blood and
what um the the the volumetric analysis
of the tumor via imaging is delivering
to the to the uh
the physician um at at the same time so
mutation information from sequencing of
plasma dna correlates well with tumor
volume in this particular uh uh
in this particular data set
what's perhaps more interesting is when
they disagree
and so researchers are investigating
whether or not
we can use this information as an
additional line of evidence
in collab in in conjunction with
imaging information and sometimes they
don't agree so newman at all looked at
these other patients where um in the
first panel in panel e you can see that
their
molecular signature drops to zero um at
the at the time point uh marked number
four uh whereas the tumor volume stays
relatively high and so if all one had to
go on was the tumor volume you would
perhaps think that this patient was not
responding to the therapy um i saw a
recent presentation by this this uh
author um at
ashg recently and in fact this
particular patient continues on today
and is disease free
more than a significant amount of time
later
in panel f the opposite phenomenon is
occurring the red line is the plasma
based circulating tumor dna metric where
you can see it's almost unchanged in
response to therapy versus the tumor
volume has decreased to zero so again if
the practicing physician we're only
looking at the tumor volume as the
measure of whether or not the therapy
has been successful
they would think that they had complete
remission in this particular patient
unfortunately this patient did not show
remission and then uh had progressive
disease and then eventually died from
his cancer
later on and so in this particular
instance one would see this suggests
that the plasma measurement was a more
uh sensitive measure of disease burden
um in this patient and is important
information potentially to keep
available going forward
so
another open question in the space is
how many different cancer types do we
think are releasing their dna into the
bloodstream and so how widely applicable
is uh plasma based sequencing
and the study again of the johns hopkins
group
that looked at many many different
tumor types suggests that the the
presence of tumor dna in the bloodstream
is a wide widely um
consistent phenomenon across different
cancer types with the exception perhaps
being a blood-based or sorry brain-based
tumors and the range in terms of tumor
fraction within the plasma
is highly variable as
shown on the bottom panel
but
clearly across a wide range is amenable
to next generation sequencing approaches
they also showed some really interesting
uh data in this paper from earlier this
year
of the potential to use plasma based
sequencing to monitor for drug
resistance emerging drug resistance so
in this figure from the paper they have
a series of patients colorectal patients
that have been put on egfr uh blockade
treatment and you can see pre-treatment
they have no mutations in their
k rash gene or pig 3 ca genes
when we look at their
mutational status in their bloodstream
post treatment
in fact many of these patients have
now shown
evidence of canonical resistance
pathways kicking up mutations in k-rests
for example
or uh additional mutations in the egfr
gene that would render their
current egfr blockade therapy
ineffective
and so this is
again a small study only a couple dozen
patients but suggests that potentially
deep sequencing serial deep sequencing
of
known resistance genes throughout the
course of therapy can be an early
indicator of emerging resistance um and
potentially be useful for switching
therapies down the road now there's a
huge amount of clinical research and
an exploration that has to be done here
to truly understand the potential
but these early proof of principle
studies i think are really
exciting in in the suggestions that they
they make for the future of this field
so to wrap things up um i hope i've
given you a whirlwind tour of some of
the things that we're excited about
working on here at aluminum um and the
the areas that we hope to be developing
technologies in going forward uh
germline variation further exploration
of tumor biology and tumor profiling and
then molecular monitoring
and uh using our technology deep
sequencing across all three of these uh
uh sort of areas of exploration going
forward
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and i'd be happy to take
any questions
okay if there's no questions then i will
wrap things up and i thank you so much
for your participation and your
attendance today and uh hope to see you
again bye
you